Mack I'm dancing again and by crashing
my question is when are you sleeping not
at the moment
it is whew very rarely did you also just
move I just moved yep I got a new house
finally has some new furniture okay so
one yeah it's sort of all grouping you
thought to yourself I'm gonna get two
new shows I'm gonna have a new baby and
I'm gonna move into a new house yeah you
know what's today you you can't you
don't plan things in life you sort of
put out everything that you want and
then we don't always say like oh yeah
but it's actually been it's been good
and it's it manageable I'm really
excited about soundtrack coming out
because it was like such a labor of love
doing the show and it's really unique
and different and fresh and I cannot
wait for people to see this the song or
the show has this great thing where it's
all about finding the perfect song for
every moment if you had a song for the
moment that your life isn't right now
what would it be
this is a lot of pressure I did put you
right on the spot it's a song from my
life right now I'm so excited oh yeah oh
yeah you celebrate there you go yeah
y'all have me singing on camera Steve's
gonna make fun of this I can already
hear it well he's very professional yeah
he's the singer in this family okay but
you're the dancer I mean how did you
feel when you heard I'm lip-synching on
this show yes I was completely intrigued
I had a meeting with Josh Safran who's
the creator of the show a year prior to
the show being made and he was like I
have this great idea really wonderful
drama intersecting love stories all of
this is us but we're gonna do musical
numbers and but you're not singing your
lip-syncing and it's going to be
something really exciting with people to
watch and he told me a couple of
concepts of the numbers and they felt
like my dream music videos of me
pretending to be a pop star what I've
always wanted to do I was like I don't
care what I'm doing I will drop
everything to do this show I love that
and you guys really had to get the
lip-synching right yeah can you give me
some tips and tricks if I lip-sync I
have to say lip-synching is really hard
I have a whole new appreciation for pop
stars in general after doing this show
but lip syncing is difficult you because
it's all about the breath you literally
have to breathe at the exact right time
you don't want to overdo the mouth
movements you don't want to under do
them it is it took me hours and hours
and hours and hours of working to get it
exactly right
because there's a difference between
just singing along in the car and then
doing it precisely right
okay did Steve help you with lip
synching or as a singer season he
happens to be one of the best lip
singers I have ever seen in my entire
life and yeah he did help me he totally
helped me heat its breath work it's
where the singer breathe it's knowing
how they they're inflection with certain
things and you have to sing it there's
no real lip-syncing so did you really
sing it yes I did
so you can really sing that track better
never come out you're like someone as
the audio they better turn that mic off
I'm like just sing yeah hot mic hot mic
on soundtrack my nightmare okay but
between Steve singing you're now
lip-syncing and you're dancing what is
you guys this house like is it just a
constant musical number it's pretty
musical my daughter's really musical
Evie loves to dance and sing around the
house Steve's always playing music
I'm always we're always kind of dancing
yet is this baby gonna be a
grammy-winning never no never no you see
we'll see but definitely I mean music is
gonna be in the genes that's for sure
[Music]